there is a story from a couple years ago
here in Massachusetts what's known
colloquially as the texting suicide case
it's a tragic and quite quite
interesting and disturbing story
Michelle Carter was 17 years old in 2014
when via text message she encouraged her
then boyfriend to kill himself and he
did Michelle Carter was charged with
manslaughter she was convicted and the
judge said she caused the death of the
18 year old when she told him to get
back into his truck as it was filling
with carbon monoxide she sent dozens of
text messages urging her boyfriend Roy
to follow through on his talk of taking
his own life saying that the time is
right and he's ready and the juvenile
court judge Lawrence Moniz also
sentenced Carter late last week to five
years of probation in addition to a
minimum 15 month jail term which has
been temporarily suspended pending
appeal so this is a very very legally
interesting story for a few different
reasons number one the argument was made
during the trial by Carter's lawyer that
her boyfriend was already determined to
kill himself and that nothing that
Carter did could have changed that so
the fact that she was encouraging it was
not actually responsible for her
boyfriend taking his own life there's a
another argument to be made as well
which is that if you start telling any
random person that they should take
their own life if that's someone who is
not already predisposed to do that or
suffering from depression it's not going
to make a difference right if you go to
a person that is emotionally healthy and
you say it's time for you to take your
own life
you're ready it's time to do it that
will have absolutely no impact
whatsoever so it's complicated because
whether this type of message would even
have an impact depend on the victim in
as much as it depends on the perpetrator
because you are not going to be able to
no matter how convincing Michelle Carter
could have been there are many people
that she never would have been able to
convinced to kill themselves and that is
why there are some who see this and say
she deserves a light sentence not only
because she was 17 at the time and this
is a juvenile court case
but because these are comments which
really were impactful because of the
emotional state of the victim in this
case you buy that you think that's a
good defense I don't know that's why
this is such a complicated case and why
there was so much media attention
towards it let me lay out two more
arguments one from each side on one hand
you have her exercising her right to
free speech you'd think because she's
not making threats and of course she's
not the one that killed him he killed
himself but the question is did the
messages cause him which we definitely
she encouraged him to go back into the
car and he ultimately killed himself via
carbon monoxide poisoning correct and
there's also this idea of a duty to
rescue where if someone's in peril or
they're about to die from a medical
incident or what have you then you have
a duty to go out go and help them and it
seems like she was doing something
they'll completely counter to that and
if you and and you may not mean
physically help but at least notify
authorities absolutely that this is
someone whose life is at risk here and
in addition to that there is the layer
of her being a juvenile because her age
it is considered that because of her age
she has a better chance of
rehabilitation and as a result it would
justify a lighter sentence there's also
mental illness as a possibility on her
behalf right it's hard to surmise
whether she truly thought suicide would
be better for him or whether she's a
psychopath there are many layers to this
and it is very complex and people here
in Massachusetts have been quite torn
actually over over this case and over
the verdict so I really care rinsable
that odds here that's for sure there are
principles at odds and I'd be curious to
hear from the audience about this
eventual not only verdict but also
sentenced